[Musique]
alors sur ces images du canada toutes
saisons c'est comme les tenues tout
saison ça passe partout j'étais saison
vous avez du vert du bleu du blanc
bienvenue au canada bienvenue à tam tam
canada en direct de montréal c'est le
vendredi comme vous le savez le vendredi
que ce soit ici ou ailleurs dans
l'ensemble des écoles du monde entier
c'est la fête
évidemment parce que c'est la fête oui
c'est ça bonjour à tous et bienvenue à
nos collègues aussi en studio on amaris
jobin qui est avec nous bonjour ses fins
alice chantal champ des carmes comme
gong
bonjour il fut une époque je me plais
stéphane bernard par le pont me
différencie de bernard parent le look
airs bien connus et entre temps à vous
avez changé mon bahut disparu alors moi
j'ai assumé le non non non ce que l'on
croit ouais aujourd'hui vous avez quatre
éditions à elle perdure c'est on a beau
à s'approcher de noël nous ici à
l'émission une tradition qui dure
toutes les semaines de l'année c'est le
fait que vous ne connaissez pas le sujet
des missions ne le dira jamais bon des
fois oui parce que espionner on vous a
déjà vu espionner oui ça fait pas partie
de mon c'était par hasard cette erreur
n'était pas erreur ou entendu les
invités parler de l'émission avant le
voilà là aujourd'hui on a deux invités
sur un sujet qui veut moi me fascine je
suis sûr que je vais en apprendre alors
ça maintenant à vous de jouer on vous
montre la vidéo 5 images tout le monde
ailleurs dans le monde joue également
cinq images pour devenir le sujet
aujourd'hui l'émission c'est pas facile
c'est pas évident ça se passe en afrique
ça c'est en afrique sur la corne de
l'afrique
ça pourrait se passer en afrique et
[Musique]
c'est sûr que atteint 10 le placer sous
quelque chose à faire avec le fils le
visage oui on fait comment vous cacher
la vérité à la reconnaissance faciale
bien un thème bien précis par rapport à
ça la voix soul voici le thème les faces
cachées de la reconnaissance faciale qui
font sourciller
parce qu'apparemment on peut on peut
lire vos émotions grâce à vous sur six
sites web qui est consacrée à ça et j'en
suis sûr la technologie s'y intéresse
également
mais la caisse qu'à vivre avec le fait
que maintenant les gens font leurs
sources y un peu plus gros ou encore tu
as peut-être un certaine culture on ne
sourcille pas la même façon s'ils sont
plus gros vous êtes une plus grosse
cible pour les policiers c'est sûr si
vous sur six est très belle et bonne
chance de vous faufiler pourquoi c'est
si sûr pourquoi c'est sûr qu'est ce qui
est si sûr mais si la saucisse en plus
gros on est plus facilement cibler par
la police ne parlait pas des saucisses
là mais des sources y voit alors là je
sais écouter c'est le vendredi
non je suis amusée la trêve de plaisir
on y va avec notre premier tour
aujourd'hui de la grosse boule qui est
consacrée bien sûr à cet univers
fascinant des de la reconnaissance
faciale et c'est un sujet qui intéresse
tout le monde autour de la planète j'en
suis sûr à faire mais aussi les
canadiens bien sûr selon siby si nous
donc selon le pendant anglophone de
radio-canada noc est tout à fait récente
le mois dernier au sujet de la
reconnaissance faciale dites-moi
laquelle de ces affirmations est vrai
vous avez le choix de réponses possibles
à le service de police de montréal
l'utilisent déjà
b le service de police de montréal ne
l'utilisent plus c'est le service de
police de montréal ne l'a jamais
utilisée ou d aucune de ces réponses
jusqu'à quel point vous en savez des
choses sur la reconnaissance faciale
autour de vous c'est ce moyen d'y
j'hésiterais un tracé où des alors le ne
l'a jamais utilisée et aucune de ces
réponses
moi j'irai pour la réponse d d aucune de
ces réponses alors quelle serait la
réponse c'est aucune de ces réponses
qu'elle serait là j'allais avec des
outils mais aussi à bon alors écoutez on
va afficher la bonne réponse
il s'agit de vous avez conservé ou
perdre vos 20 boules sur les sur le
saint paul sur l'autre voilà voulait
conserver 80 bull a joué au fur et à
mesure de l'émission les prochains jours
sans vouloir vous avez conservé vos
vingt premières boules voici la réalité
voici ce qui se passe on a demandé à la
police de montréal est ce que vous
l'utilisez pas où vous devez déjà
utilisé comme les journalistes sont ils
osent pas posé de questions directement
voici la réponse elle ne veut pas dire
si elles l'utilisent déjà ou non cette
technologie la reconnaissance faciale à
ne pas dire ben qui ne dit rien consent
ce qu'on sait ce parcours c'est que à
calgary il utilise à toronto ils ont
même eu un projet pilote lancé l'an
dernier là dessus ils l'utilisent c'est
passé deux seules grandes villes
canadiennes qui l'utilisent c'est bien
l'angleterre soit utilisée et ça
commence à être controversé
ben c'est là où ils ont beaucoup
beaucoup de caméras derrière lui la
ville est surveillé 24h 24 on va parler
des caméras surveillant vers un peu plus
tard l'émission je pense ça fera même
l'objet d'une autre question pourquoi
pas moi je vais vous proposer ici au
sujet du service de police politique
pour l'os j'ai vu ça ce matin j'ai
trouvé ça intéressant c'est un problème
qu'on partage à travers la planète
escorte 11 yards veut présenter la vidéo
numéro 2 prévu à l'émission ce que dix
cartons garde au sujet des caméras et de
la reconnaissance faciale par caméra
s'est hissée ils ont fait ils ont marre
ils ont fait un rapport pourront
commander un rapport et ont conclu que
la technologie utilisée par et seulement
il est inexact à 80% pour quatre fois
sur cinq on se trompe
lorsqu'on dit c'est monsieur untel
monsieur untel house et madame chantal
vacants d'accord ça c'est une étude
parmi d'autres il ya d'autres résultats
non ça fait partie des failles de cette
technologie dans ses potins je ne sais
pas moi je pense spécialistes on va
demander à nadia seraiocco et de l'école
des médias de l'université du québec à
montréal qui est spécialisée
technologies numériques de nous aider de
nous éclairer bonjour nadia alors
j'aimerais savoir si la première
question que mais vu ce matin en ayant
cette statistique de ce rapport demandé
comment des parce qu'il met garde
est ce que c'est vrai que c'est pas
aussi précis qu'on veut nous le faire
croire
cette reconnaissance faciale écoutez la
reconnaissance faciale être va être
aussi précise que les bases de données
qu'on a aussi pour comparer pour voir
les différences visage parce que la
reconnaissance sociale elle se fait
quand on va mettre des points sur votre
visage pour vous identifier les points
de lumière et l'a ensuite il encore
faut-il que votre visage soit dans une
base de données qu'il y ait d'autres
visages pour comparer ce que si vous ce
que c'est pour vous et là je pense que
où on en est présentement c'est qu'on
ramasse beaucoup d'imagés en ligne à des
compagnies qui se spécialise en soi pour
éventuellement avoir suffisamment de
données pour dire est-ce que c'est
stephano sais pas si tu es fan est ce
qu'on peut comparer comment est ce que
l'intelligence artificielle qui est
derrière ça peut aller faire des
comparatifs qui déduit que c'est bel et
bien vous qui s'ouvre une photo ou une
captation à partir d'une caméra je
lisais encore une fois ce matin je sens
mais que mes collègues tripes et ne
veulent pas chez moi vous poser une
question dont je parlais seconde vie
j'ai dû ce matin 100 millions
d'américains sont présentement fichiers
par photo en ce moment même le président
trump a demandé c'était une déclaration
en 2017 si c'est que les grandes
signatures qui l'aï mal ah bon il fait
une déclaration présidentielle il faut
que tout soit fiché prochainement
essentiellement il veut que les services
policiers soient tous connectés il est
des banques de dray il va vite en
affaires
quelle est la situation au canada au
niveau du nombre de canadiens qui
seraient déjà dans une banque d'image
prennent ces révisions je n'ai pas le
chiffre exact mais vous savez que il ya
des enquêtes des en-cas que des études
qui se font présentement même après
partir par exemple des deals de vidéos
qui sont déjà allés
d'image qui sont déjà en ligne on a vu
tout récemment le corps par exemple des
gens qui sont des militants dans
différentes organisations pour les
droits humains qui se sont aperçus
qu'ils étaient l'objet d'un fichage
internationale est ce qu'on faisait
c'est qu'on les fichiers afin de pouvoir
reconnaître des visages en mouvement
parce que vous savez vous reconnaître
sur une photo le fixe c'est assez facile
mais qui se posent encore ne captait une
vidéo sur une place publique où il y
avait une manifestation pour reconnaître
les personnes qui sont là il faut que
l'intelligence artificielle donc les
algorithmes etc tu fouilles dans les
bases de données soit capable de voir
votre visage quand il de trois quarts
est ce que c'est bien vous est ce que
c'est pour vous et c'est probablement
pour ça que jusqu'à maintenant c'est pas
concluants encore le ce qu'ils arrivent
à faire
je n'ai pas de chiffres pour le canada
il semble que j'en ai pas j'en ai pas
vus je peux vous dire quand même que la
technologie avance très rapidement et
que la somme des documents qui en ligne
sur les individus des vidéos des photos
etc sur des personnalités connues aussi
a aidé énormément constituer son voeu le
pool de données qui va permettre
éventuellement de vous reconnaître même
en mouvement dans une foule ou de
reconnaître une personnalité connue 100
millions d'américains qui ont un dossier
ça ne veut pas dire qu'on peut les
reconnaître encore avec précision
ça veut dire qu'on y travaille par
exemple sont quand on donne des chiffres
le sait qu'au nord on attend des
dossiers alors non on est en train
d'essayer de les étoffer pour arriver un
tour de reconnaissance qui soit près de
100 pour sal
alice qui déjà fiché orange
j'en sais rien peut-être que je le suis
bon ben j'allais vous demander nadia
seraiocco dans quelle mesure peut-on
considérer que cette technologie la
porte atteinte aux lignes aux libertés
individuelles
on n'est pas toujours content de se voir
ainsi capté au passage est ce qu'on ne
devrait pas tracer une réelle ligne de
démarcation entre les enjeux
sécuritaires et
je veux dire c'est la liberté la liberté
publique vous poser une question qui est
tout à fait propos et qui d'ailleurs se
retrouve beaucoup en carton et en milieu
universitaire dans les considérations
qu'on est là dessus le problème qu'on a
en ce moment c'est très souvent ces
initiatives la soie ne sont pas
divulguées publiquement avant d'avoir
des résultats
ou encore se font en parle sur deux
compagnies de sécurité
vous saurez que les caméras qui captent
votre visage et qui peuvent par des
bases de données vous reconnaître
l'appui 10 rebonds 26 et alice justement
qui passait dans telle place publique
ben il y en a 200 millions d'installer
en chine c'est un des grands vendeurs de
ces équipements là au japon on est aussi
parmi les grands producteurs et comme
ceux en israël aussi et tous ces gens là
pour vendre leur technologie doivent
justement la tester et pour l'attester
qu'est ce qu'ils font mais utilise des
photos des vidéos des bases de données
et on s'aperçoit de plus en plus que ces
bases de données le sont souvent conçues
à notre insu a fait quand vous parlez de
droits et libertés on s'imagine bien que
la technologie nous vient de chez malo
où on installe et crédit social puis on
moniteur les citoyens une bonne façon
inégale et c'est pas tout à fait ce
qu'on souhaite voir arriver au canada
tente est tellement que des états
américains oea qui eux m'ont des lois
déjà contre la captation à votre insu
des données biométriques c'est à dire
votre visage tout ce qui touche le
fonctionnement biologique etc
parce que on a beau dire mais si vous
pouvez changer votre numéro de compte de
banque
votre visage ça fait c'est un petit peu
plus complexe ans pour y arriver et le
sait c'est là qu'on en est c'est quand
on est conscient que c'est une intrusion
la vie privée que vous devriez était
visée mais vous savez qui est
présentement dans des initiatives
marketing même au québec qui se sont
fait ou on capte les visages des gens
pour analyser leurs émotions en
marketing et le les gens entre danseuses
entre dans un centre d'achat ne savent
pas qu'ils sont captés mais une petite
pancarte quelque part qui dit est par
hasard vous savez que si on peut capter
votre visage si vous regardez de vitrine
afin de cumuler des données marketing
sur les émotions des consommateurs mais
tout ça effectivement
ainsi sont des petites entorses qui
s'accumulent à notre vie privée
on s'en rend pas compte
effectivement tout d'un coup vous êtes
rendu fiché dans une base de données qui
peut-être pas effective à quelque 1 400
% et vous pourriez vous retrouver
peut-être même mise en cause dans un
crémant quelque chose que vous n'avez
aucune affaire ne vous n'avez pas avoir
quand même très inquiétant
on ne laisserai pas si on ne serait pas
ses cartes de crédit comme se traîner
partout mais notre image est de plus en
plus à utiliser toutes sortes de fins
sans notre permission
est ce que ça veut dire que ce genre de
fichage devrait faire partie de
changement dans la loi pour le droit à
la vie privée
présentement je voudrais le commissaire
à la vie privée s'est intéressé beaucoup
aussi au fait que nos données en général
c'est à dire les données qu'on met sur
facebook qui sont diffusées sur google
qui sont captés par le téléphone souvent
surtout tu faisais défunt dont on n'est
même pas soupçons oui exactement
marketing mercantile et même de
surveillance parce que ça rappelez vous
un g2 beaumont pour vous cambridge en
r&d tk halal halal est scandale de
captation des données sur facebook qui a
des données qui ont été réutilisés pour
mener à bon terme l'élection de
tremblant suite
toutes ces choses là à ces entorses la
démocratie se font souvent par à partir
de bases de données qu'on a cédé
j'aiderai volontairement mais qui ont
déjà lu le contrat d'utilisation de
facebook ou d'instagram ou de gougaud à
cette fin pas de grand monde et qu'à
chaque fois que ça change
on est de plus en plus mystifié par
lesquels ils comptent sur il commissaire
à la vie privée si ce que c'était le
premier pas qui faisait au canada
est-ce qu'on pourrait revoir ci contrôle
à s'intéresser à ça parce que
présentement les données des citoyens
canadiens sont usés à toutes sortes
d'usagés marketing et on pense que c'est
ça dépend ça dépend ce vraiment là la
protection de ce qu'on devrait faire en
termes de protection de la vie privée
professeur on va poursuivre cette
analyse questions éthiques et morales
liées à l'utilisation de ces
technologies avec notre second invité
dans quelques instants mais en ce qui
nous concerne
en ce qui concerne votre domaine de
spécialité bref j'avais entendu parler
de ça il ya eu un vol de photographies à
la frontière américaine
au début de cette année ou au printemps
des milliers de fichiers de personnes de
photographies de canadiens qui ont été
volés on ne sait pas trop par qui la
frontière américaine alors qu'ils
accueillent les canadiens avec sourire
évidemment et quels sont les échanges de
données qui existent ou les entende
échanges de données entre le canada et
les états unis le canada et la chine
peut-être un jour mais là vous voyez au
niveau des échanges de données
moi je pense que c'est là qu'un des
vases communicants qui sont périlleux
c'est ça ça ressemble à des glissades
ben écoutez d'abord on a toutes sortes
de problèmes du dre de teknologik qu'on
ne voit pas toujours ces données là
quand elles sont captés me pardonnez moi
ils vont être entreposées sur des
serveurs souvent aux états unis même
quand on parle de facebook de google est
déjà là c'est un premier problème quand
on parle il me pardonnez moi le rhume a
été dur cette année robert ses profits
non c'est pas fini ce temps encore lada
et dont est ce qu'on s'aperçoit c'est
que le problème déjà et là on vous le
dit on vole des on vole des photos
évidemment que ce conte dont nous on en
oublie souvent c'est que nos fameuses
intelligence artificielle qui servent à
nous reconnaître un ce sont comme des
enfants qu'il faut finalement nourrir
entraîné pour quels grands artistes
qu'elle devienne plus performante et on
les nourrit de quoi on les nourrit de
vous donner de vos photos de vos vidéos
de vos données personnelles pour qu'elle
devienne plus performante à reconnaître
une personne quand on parle de
reconnaissance faciale
il faut donc des bases de données
thérèse étoffé sur les types de
personnes les couleurs de peau lit les
types de visage et caetera et l'eau les
intelligences ancien apprennent à tracer
des parallèles appelés à nouveau à
gauche devrait saisir encore mieux et
c'est pour ça qu'on va en entendre
parler vous me parlez de ce vol là je
pourrais vous parler justement de
beaucoup d'autres dossiers de la même
nature dans la dernière année
et à chaque fois quand on finit par
trouver la source de ces valeurs ce sont
des compagnies qui généralement travail
pour des idées comme oeuvre je dirais
fourni ça pour de la défense dans des
pays qui veulent utiliser ce à des fins
soit d'espionnage ou encore de
reconnaissance faciale de leurs propres
citoyens mais qu'on est toujours dans ce
paradigme option ne le comprend
bien encore comme citoyens les gens ont
encore de la difficulté à comprendre la
valeur que peut avoir leur visage c'est
pas juste pour me reconnaître mois qu'on
veut mais photo c'est aussi pour
justement garnir ses bases a donné là
les étayer puis pouvoir ensuite effectué
plus efficacement des tâches de
reconnaissance des tâches de ciblage des
citoyens et des tâches de surveillance
aussi à des fins souvent la dre de
coercition dans certains pays puis tous
appuyé à la turballe le canada souvent
on essaie de rester neutre mais là comme
je le dis présentement au moment où on
se parle
nos données sont déjà sur des serveurs
américains en très grande en est
justement j'allais poser la question de
savoir ce qu il ne serait pas pertinent
s qui ne serait pas temps que le canada
crée son propre système info nuagiques
pour stocker les informations privées
des canadiens et faire en sorte que ce
ne soit plus totalement exposés à la
merci de certains gouvernements
étrangers
je pense que c'est effectivement là
qu'on devrait aller
déjà je sais que le gouvernement
canadien ont beaucoup de serveurs etc
pour entreposer nous donner parce que
les tuiles sont assez prudents là quand
on va dans chaque province veut avoir
des fonctionnements différents certains
certains vont même choisir au québec on
a ce conflit-là a été n présentement le
gouvernement suggère de prendre une
solution américaine pour entreposer les
données des mimes et moi et ça nous
dérange comme expert du numérique moi ça
me dérange énormément énormément
oui parce que déjà quand c'est sur un
autre territoire s'est soumis à d'autres
lois potentiellement on ne peut pas
influencer à ce moment là ce qui va se
passer là si cette compagnie le désir de
se reprenne deux ou trois mois puis de
fermer boutique
qu'est-ce qu'on fait nos données sont
toutes là tout est entreposé là comment
est ce qu'on les récupère donc on a
intérêt oui d'abord en plus heures d'un
point de vue strictement économique en
développant une expertise canadienne
puis des services canadiens ça ne peut
qu'être notre avantage
et en plus tu urbain un côté sécurité ça
veut dire que des organismes comme le
commissaire à la vie privée comme nos
gouvernements les organismes qui ont
juridiction aussi vont pouvoir décider
peut-être même en enfin faire comme
certains pays et se doter d'une
politique sur la gestion des données
comme le règlement général la protection
des données en europe
hello tout d'un coup on serait maître je
dirais ou chez nous au canada de nos
données et on pourrait être part
peut-être même si des rebelles
on ne veut pas que les données des
canadiens soit utilisée at-elle fait que
vous fassiez telle ou telle chose on
aurait plus de latitude pour justement
protéger nos données et éduquer les gens
ici sur comment gérer nos propres
données
là durant on a finalement presque toutes
les bonnes informations concernant votre
visage jusqu'à maintenant on a une
dernière question pour oui en fait
jusqu'où devrait en faire confiance
parce qu'enfin une relation de confiance
qui devrait exister normalement entre le
gouvernement du québec et ses géants du
web basé aux états unis qui stocke nos
informations j'ai discuté avec quelques
représentants de google et d'amazon qui
me disent ben c'est une question de
confiance on n'est pas prêts à divulguer
les informations comme ça au
gouvernement américain
est-ce qu'on devrait effectivement faire
confiance à ces gens là ces compagnies
là je vous dirais que d'abord on est on
a déjà le doigt dans l'engrenage pour
pas dire ans qu'on a le breucq pris
jusqu'à l'épaule le phare du temps dans
ses cheveux cela laisse qu'il faut se
dire c'est que pour dire qu'on a
vraiment des relations de confiance en
que plusieurs brèches à cette confiance
surtout quand on regarde du côté de
facebook avec par exemple le fameux
scandale qui à vrai dire danticat et de
multiples fuites de données
donc rien n'est parfait et pour parler
d'une relation de confiance il faut
qu'on puisse négocier un jeu dre d'égal
à égal et ça c'est très difficile parce
que ce sont des géants pour pas dire des
titans du numérique et de l'économie
numérique
et là moi je me sens seule façon de le
voir c'est le canada est un pays à qui
quand même de huy citoyens ont chacun je
devais bénéficié d'un double j'aiderai
d'un budget annuel et c'est fort
intéressant pour ces compagnies là on
devrait effectivement négocié plus
j'apprécie énormément quand les gens par
exemple ce soit monsieur legault québec
où nos dirigeants ou pas les canadiens
vont les rencontrer pour négocier parce
qu'on n'aura pas le choix
mais négocier ça veut aussi dire
demander des choses en retour et l'on ne
pas demander grand chose jusqu'à
maintenant et ça c'est vraiment un point
où il faut vraiment se dire quand
l'europe
si des deux mètres le règlement général
sur la protection des données en vigueur
en mai 2018
ils ont peu attendu je dirais
l'approbation des géants du web et les
géants du web commence tranquillement à
organiser leur règlement leur contrat de
gestion avec nous du leur contrat
d'utilisation pour satisfaire l'europe
donc en l'uniforme est un petit peu
ailleurs fait que c'est à dire quelqu'un
ils ont pas trop le choix
ils commencent à considérer des
solutions alternatives donc nous fournir
plus de données sur comment gérer nous
donnait justement comment protéger mieux
ce qu'on met en ligne dès que c'est un
peu à nous comme comme et a finalement
d'aller les rencontrer puis de dire bon
ok voici le nom on a presque 40 millions
de personnes n'y en ait que plus de 80 %
qui sont qu'utilise vos services
on va se parler mais on va essayer de
faire les choses ses seuls 6,7
proactivité l'aja pense que les états
vont devoir développer de plus en plus
en face à céret au cos est entendue il
ya pas de problème vous avez l'emploi on
vous allez négociatrice c'est promis
c'est vrai dans ce rôle là oui ces cieux
cet excellent ton avis merci beaucoup
pour votre science et votre information
aujourd'hui c'est très apprécié quelque
chose me dit aux étudiants doivent avoir
dû briser mais il me dit qu'elle écoute
et on est prêt pour l'action en studio
on a encore des boules à perdre ou à
gagner ou à conserver un conserver
surtout tambouille dans ce deuxième jeu
sont en jeu voici la question à la fiche
pour le plaisir le bonheur de tous
deuxième tour voici la question selon un
sondage visa donc l'émetteur de cartes
de crédit quel pourcentage des
consommateurs canadiens veulent passer
sont prêts à passer à la biométrie donc
à l'utilisation des informations dans le
visage les yeux dans les sourcils dans
les empreintes digitales pour que ça ait
pu rapidement à la caisse pour un client
de fiabilité à partir du moment où il ya
des failles
ouais quel pourcentage de quelques
chansons synthèse pour le plus faible en
six bourses entre 6 et 36 % 60 des deux
d'accord mais y'en à pia pas de abyss ya
à 100% b36 ses 56 ou des 80
ce bonne réponse c'est b b pour chantal
et la bourse et à
c'est pour çà a pour m pour maryse 6%
on affiche la bonne réponse tout le
monde on va moi je me souviens plus
voilà je trouve que les gens font
beaucoup confiance aux géants ils sont
prêts à le faire voici les résultats en
détail je ressens ce fantastique mois
fin très intéressant comme journée des
sources a plutôt étonnant de 6 à 10 %
des consommateurs canadiens connaissent
déjà la biométrie à quoi ça ressemble
donc ça les inquiète plus ou moins 86 %
des consommateurs souhaitent l'utiliser
pour vérifier leur identifié identité
éviter d'avoir des problèmes de votre
passé d'une bonne chose ou pas leurs
yeux
65% pensent que la biométrie plus facile
à utiliser que tout le reste et 44 pour
cent croient qu'elle est plus
sécuritaire que l'utilisation évidemment
des moluques est mais beaucoup plus
invasive à écouter vous vous ou soulever
des questions intéressantes on va
déposer un expert en éthique et
conseiller à la commission de l'éthique
en sciences et en technologie du québec
il s'agit de david rocheleau hall
monsieur ou le bonze rocheleau roule
bonjour alors vous avez entendu notre
invité précédente qui vous a grugé un
peu de terrain qui a déjà mis la table
en parlant d'une entente qui a été
établie en europe en 1912 1900 en 2018
que le québec que le canada ferait bien
d'adopter ce genre d'entente là au
niveau de la réflexion des réflexions de
votre commission puisque les choses
auront plan technologique avance vite et
les lois avance c'est leur nature un peu
lentement
où en est la discussion au sein de votre
comité de conseil
l'adduction on est d'accord ou début mai
donc des jeunes et d'avancer dangereux
il faut donc c'est un aspect de dégâts
mais aussi comprendre l'idée comme une
valeur c'est à dire être fait de son
unité en vue et le droit de vivre
constamment ethnie il pourrait être le
cas par exemple
donc c'était au visage un autre des
enjolivements minutes concernant
l'utilisation de ces deux
reconnaissances face à donner le sens
commercial d'un stand il pourrait
trouver un objectif mais un temps
d'avertir un contact de manière libre et
éclairé f
il y va on va écourter cette entrevue à
moins de pouvoir avoir un meilleur son
ça nous parle du tout assuré on a
beaucoup de progrès à faire au niveau de
l'image sans ici quelques pas au niveau
de la technologie skype sais pas si on
peut ajuster vous aviez une question
pour notre invité oui on parle est un
taux de 86 % des canadiens qui
aimeraient faire appel à la biométrie
pour des questions de sécurité
comment justifier une telle popularité
compte tenu des enjeux négatifs qui sont
soulevés y est je le fais c'est beaucoup
plus facile de donner dans son staff un
mot de passe et réalité higuain ouais
ouais
éloigné de nous pour vaillance mais pour
numéro quatre en or alors que mélo
constat regagner le désavantage ballon
d'or peut être écourtée cette
conversation parce que l'on comprend le
sens général de ce que vous avez à dire
mais je pense que par des mots on perd
beaucoup ça arrive une fois de temps en
temps écoutez ce qu'on va faire si
ajouté un hyperlien qui mène vers votre
que votre conseil pour que les gens
puissent aller chercher de l'information
sur ce que vous faites actuellement pour
essayer de de baliser l'arrivée delà de
ces technologies technologies net et un
trailer est invité à une autre membre va
trouver un moyen de refaire quelque
chose avec vous et éventuellement je
vous remercie beaucoup de vous d'avoir
accepté de ne vous joindre à nous
aujourd'hui
alors c'était marc andré deschamps
pardonnez moi mais c'était david roche
la houle
j'ai de la difficulté qui n'ont composer
depuis quelques temps changent d'avis
chantal chante des airs connus à ce que
je trouvais intéressant à ces
conversations qu'on a eus avec ses deux
invités c'est que c'est des
consommateurs sont déjà intéressé
curieux et on est en leur vin la
facilité jetons un faux sentiment de
sécurité
parce qu'en réalité le consommateur est
obligé lui de faire les démarches numéro
6 vidéo est obligé de faire les
démarches pour essayer de se relever de
ce système là ici là qui est le problème
d'après moi et j'aimerais bien aller
comprendre c'est quoi le profil des
personnes qui sont favorables à cette
technologie
on parle de 86 % des canadiens qui sont
ils en général c'est les gens qui sont
outils 1 va pas vraiment les enjeux
qu'il estime menacées
une vidéo de ce qui se passe en chine
faisant vous faites votre épicerie il ya
personne en magasin tout se fait par
caméra on vous reconnaît ben on sait qui
vous êtes
c'est pas la première fois que vous y
allez y a pas de question à la personne
ici vous voyez on sait tout de suite
parce qu'on le voit les caméras sont
partouche pas ils ont montré 63 caméras
à l'intérieur de l'établissement
vous pensez que ça c'est le futur c'est
le présent enchaîner ça pourrait être le
présent canada mais ça commence
d'ailleurs je les ai vus dans les temps
que l'épicerie encore il y en a une qui
ce but un projet dans la mine épiceries
métro au québec oui je pense qu'il est
urgent que c'était là je mets ça a été
et mauvaise réaction quelle est la vraie
décision
on parle d'économie on parle de
consommation
est ce qu'il ya des moments de la
journée aussi à plus de gens on peut
charger plus cher selon la personne et
dahiri dynamique quoi c'est ça et oui un
bon on pourrait charger prix parce que
c'est électronique
il charge et plus moi je change rien à
mon siège visage qui ont approché d'une
baisse des prix mais non mais non mais
non mais je pense que j'ai enfin je veux
dire les prix ne peuvent pas changer
comme ça des fonctions de monsieur
at-elle fait 60 dollars oui il ya déjà
dix affiches nîmes et électroniques pour
les prix qu'est ce qui vous dit que les
prix a pas changé dans la dernière heure
oui au moment où vous avez mis les verts
la jce est curieux que les prix puissent
changer en fonction du client mais moi
je pense est une idée qu'il faut
absolument mettre un copyright dessus je
perdrais mon ami trompe mais une
épicerie une chaîne d'épicerie à toronto
markov pour le toronto un propriétaire
déprécie d'épicerie qui veut à m'étendre
ça à tous ses magasins et il en a
plusieurs épiceries et le problème c'est
que problème c'est que ça fait
sourciller beaucoup de gens parce que il
est c'est un copain du gouvernement
chinois
manifestation encore il était contre le
mouvement étudiant et donc il ya ce cas
une association ici
et parler des gens qui sont plus c'est
peut-être devoir adopter ce genre de
technologie est ce qu'il va falloir se
promener comme à hong kong avec un jour
d'un fichu sur le visage bon on ne va
pas se faire reconnaître
il ne riez pas c'est pour arriver
troisième jour on rit on a trop plaisir
troisième tour de la console
alors voici 50 boules à perdre
vous avez perdu combien de boue le
premier match aller perdu
on a maintenant tu te rends compte et de
vendre 70 donc là 50 boules à perdre
mais on sait que vous avez au moins
finir avec 20 boules chacun chacun
chacun chacune et juste des faits qui
répondent les boules c'est féminin c'est
vrai voilà voici troisième tour où que
je ne tiens pourquoi vous portez là il
ya des techniciens qui hérite lantieri
mais quoi plusieurs scénarios sont
possibles ici
combien y at-il de caméras de
surveillance dans le monde je pense que
nous invitez vous a donné une piste un
peu plus tôt est ce que c'est à 50
millions est ce que ces bébés 150
millions est ce que c'est c'est 250
millions ou est ce que c'est des 350
millions bonnes réponses
aucune de ces réponses mais saisie
n'existait pas alors je vais dans la
même direction
on affiche la bonne réponse pour tous et
chacun seulement il ya 350 millions de
caméras de surveillance dans le monde
tant date de 2016 à augmenter un peu de
plus
et puis 65% de ces caméras étaient
installées en asie allez ce cliché était
la question que j'allais vous posez
c'est principalement la réponse est oui
à vals en boule pour moi je peux gagner
des brumes aussi à mon âge mais bull
m'appartiennent et puis voici quoi ils
encaissent vous allez trop vite
il reste encore un peu de plaisir la
vidéo numéro attendez moi sachez que ça
déboule védas et d'émissions mairie en
bo7 pour en savoir plus sur le sujet
traité aujourd'hui
on va sur le site web châssis notre
expert en questions technologiques à la
station on a aussi trouvé des reportages
des entrevues faites pas vous deux on va
regarder avant d'aller voir si vous
pensez que vous êtes auteur d'un des
artistes qui apparaît sur la page où
vous le voyez vous une essencerie
personnes doivent pouvoir lever la cgc
canadien la première la première cible
dans le métro un montant non c'est pas
moi le fbi a et détient des photos sur
412 millions d'américains étrangers je
sais pas mais ça me dit quelque chose
serge asie je pense un peu mais on va
descendre en bas dans mon pote nous ont
donné que quelque chose soit
reconnaissance faciale et au part ça je
pense que c'est de vous alice
à l'aéroport c'est pas moi c'est pas de
vous non quoi c'est à moi j'étais pour
vérification pour ceux que ça intéresse
les reportages récents de radio canada
international là dessus et où on est
prêt pour l'image de la semaine
bon je réponds seulement par semaine ah
oui c'est vrai seulement par oui ou par
non cette fois ci c'est juré je réponds
seulement par oui ou par non
est-ce que ça se passe au canada
non pas vraiment et aux états unis à
partie un lien avec un magazine
peut-être les ménages est en berne sur
le dézonage et doit et quoi donald trump
et donnant une chance qu'elle est là
pour compléter
voici la vidéo qui montre l'image de la
semaine en fait dont il y en a deux
images il ya d'abord celle de greta à
voila voila et la 10e la tomate et wii
ainsi donald qui aurait aimé être à sa
place
ouais et on l'a mis à sa place c'est son
équipe qui a fait ça c'est si l'équipe à
son équipe électorale qui a fait ça à
l'air bien sûr de toi t es perdu du
thouarsais par rapport à une déclaration
qu'il a faite au sujet de crainte a way
il lui a dit elle ferait mieux d'aller
regarder un film avec ses amis maintien
ouais mais lui aussi devrait filer alors
voilà ça c'est la seule fois où il est
apparu sur le time magazine
plongez y les plus qu'une fois mais
j'avais grand personnalité de l'année
mais voilà quelques heures il n'y a pas
de photos de lui en première page non
tenait les times c'est dommage c'est
encore une dinde et des fleurons qui lui
manque
il attend bien stationnarité de l'année
mais on parle de lui tout le temps
pourquoi pourquoi pourquoi en rajouter
moi je dis c'est tellement évident
pourquoi souligner les choses en rouge
lorsqu'elles sont noirs et orange
et puis toutes les couleurs du monde
voilà pas de commentaire ça va mais là
faut se demander si monsieur johnson en
angleterre et monsieur toujours positif
mais on met quoi faire ou la même
coloris ce qu'on pense non mais je
parlerai pas de leur très personnel où
est pour vous voulez vous parler du
plastique
moi je pense que devrait parler
politique tout cas
la coiffe la main si ça c'est pas
sérieux les bombes et boris johnson va
pouvoir amorcer le processus de sortie
16 européen
ouais c'est fait le vote majoritaire si
on avait encore des doutes
le locataire en place et jamais elle ne
portera plus jamais l'europe
finalement on croit que la boucle
bouclée ce prix est une question de que
sa personne éventuellement l'amérique du
nord
moi je pense une bonne idée l'angleterre
faisant partie de l'amérique du nord
géographiquement c'est très rapprochées
ont peut-être par rapport aux liens
historiques à la nada absolument c'est
quand même nous nos cousins de l'autre
côté elle voudrait dire que l'ags la
terre deviendra une colonie du canada à
une époque c'était au contraire au
siècle prochain
tout est possible dans ses bras un
nouveau monde grâce aux technologies ben
c'est pas mourir parce que la
colonisation est terminé
écouter avant de casser la boule on va
se dire au revoir mon père ait coulé à
la semaine prochaine la semaine
prochaine c'est notre dernière émission
de la saison 90,8 98e saison de radio
canada international sur le web ça va
vite très vite
on sent qu'on se conserve bien à la
semaine prochaine
[Musique]